Arthur is with us in Washington DC
hi Arthur how are you hi David how are
you better than I deserve what's up
appreciate you taking my call I have a
question for you I'm currently single
but I'm soon to be married at the end of
this year
I'm currently debt-free I've been saving
all my life for you know this particular
situation where I'll get married and
purchase a home wonderful I currently I
currently have 20% that I could put
towards our house
the thing is she has some debt and I
know how you would answer if we were
single or married but we're somewhere in
between so should I continue and save
this money towards the house or when do
I address her debt after you're married
when you get home from Lebanon you pay
it off okay so so that's basically my
question because like I have that money
and I'd like to start and we are
searching for a house and like if one
does come up so the realtor fine yeah I
wouldn't do that until you're married I
would wait till you're married to buy a
house and because you don't know and you
certainly don't want to buy a home
together until you're married but but
even then it's okay to wait there's no
rush and I know it's been a dream and
it's something you're saving towards so
how much money do you have saved for the
house well - like an emergency fund you
know that would leave me another hundred
thousand or so good and how much debt
does she have I'm not quite sure the
exact them out I know it comes in three
forms of like credit cards student loan
and automobile how long have you been
engaged um suggests over a year we do
that we do talk about finances a bit you
know I haven't we didn't dive into
specifics on the exact amount it's kind
of hard to ask about that I do and I do
know no so no it's not you're getting
ready to share her bed you need to learn
about her wallet
right right like yesterday the number
one cause of divorce in North America
today is money fights and money problems
so good pre-marriage counseling good pre
marriage process includes not only full
disclosure of everything that's going on
with the money she knows everything
about your money you know everything
about her money and income but also the
then we start working to come into
agreement on how we're going to handle
money because obviously she's a
different she's more of a spender and
you're more of a saver and this is a
potential point for conflict it's not a
deal-breaker at all but buddy you need
to be talking about it and you need to
be going okay we cut up these credit
cards we're not borrowing any more on
them we're all working together we're
going to be on a budget we're going to
be able to do nice things but we're
going to pay cash for them she's going
to bring more fun into your life because
you think saving money is fun and you're
going to bring some stability and
systems and processes to her life
because that is your life and that's a
wonderful thing if two people just alike
get married Larry Burkett used to say
one of you is unnecessary so you do want
opposites to attract right but I but the
thing is you guys really need to get
full disclosure and exactly what's going
on so if you were to guess how much she
has in debt what would you guess
probably half of what I would put as a
down payment
so you need 50,000 to clear her debt
after you're married and then that
leaves you 50,000 for a house so what
would I do if I were in your shoes I
want the two of you to go through
Financial Peace University as my guest I
think you're doing pretty well
financially I know you are doing very
well financially and the two of you walk
together through that process as part of
your engagement period as part of your
pre marriage process that will get you
on the same page and it'll show you
exactly why I'm saying to do what I'm
going to suggest you do and that is I
would wait until after you're married to
buy a home and that will allow you to
save between now and then even more the
day you come home from the honeymoon you
write a check your debt-free
you have your emergency fund and then
you'll have a down payment of some size
I don't know how much you can save
between now and and the end of the year
when you get married but
you'll have a down payment of some size
50,000 it sounds like plus whatever you
say between them it'll be your down
payment and look for a home next spring
that's what I would do you will pick a
home differently after you have been
married a year then you will pick a home
before you were married you get to know
each other after that first year of
marriage we always joke and say it takes
a year of marriage to know how close to
your mother-in-law to buy point me and
you get to know each other right and so
that's why I would suggest that and I
don't even recommend you buy in the
first year really but if you want to
move that up a little I would but I'm
definitely not buy prior to the marriage
still going to live your dream it's
going to slow it down just a little bit
enter her into the equation a little bit
more this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]